we're creating wealth
in the most expansive time in history
for people that more often than not not
to say this is the case all the time but
that more often than not we're already
good
while we sit here and there's
populations like the good zone in dc in
southwest washington dc
where the average income is 14 000 a
year
and we think that that's perfectly
acceptable
like you and i also agree on the point
that poverty is a social construct that
doesn't need to exist totally
unnecessary financial technologies that
have been created recently like
cryptocurrencies
um and the utilization of web3 is the
latest sort of iteration of how we can
do it it obviously allows us to do it at
a much quicker and more efficient pace
but we could have eradicated poverty a
long time ago and this has been a
relatively recent shift though we've
been we've been able to do it for years
but there was a period when there was
genuine scarcity and not enough to go
around but we passed that point we don't
live in that time now we don't live in
that time now the second that they
started building them rockets
that looked like dildos and shooting
them up to the moon
the time had come and gone where you
could tell me that people need to be
living on the street i agree it's
completely unacceptable like completely
it was actually pre spaceship even like
we could have done this stuff the thing
that really lit a fire under me in my
brain
was during the financial crisis
2008 2009
markets crashing etc etc they print four
trillion dollars to shore up wall street
more or less
and i don't remember voting for it no
one remembers voting for it i don't
remember anyone being like where are we
gonna get the money et cetera et cetera
but i gotta tell you darius i i saw that
[ __ ] and was like we just did what we
just printed four trillion dollars to
essentially
make the banks whole
and i took from that
this incredible
revelation
that if we wanted to we could have
produced four trillion dollars worth of
wealth good services for the american
people
at any point up to then you know
if push came to shove
[Music]
this week on forward darius baxter the
co-founder and ceo of good projects an
anti-poverty organization he also won
the 2021 muhammad ali humanitarian of
the year award darius baxter coming up
on forward
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast darius baxter the co-founder and
ceo of good projects the winner of the
2021 muhammad ali humanitarian award an
anti-poverty entrepreneur welcome to the
podcast oh my gosh i'm so excited to be
here andrew
so pumped uh and you and i
are
bonding over the fact that we we both
see
that so many people are struggling with
this unnecessary
scarcity and deprivation and
unfortunately it's not just material it
actually kind of uh crushes your spirit
sometimes
yeah no 100
i think we would agree on the fact that
there's too many people that are out
here today that are operating from a
place of what i like to call a deficit
mindset
it's very easy to wake up in the morning
and make the choice that you're going to
look out into the world and be
pessimistic
you're going to look out into the world
and say that you don't want to lead with
love or that people aren't leaving with
love when they're interacting with you
but
when you operate through the wild in
that way
it oftentimes limits
your ability to see like all the amazing
things that are possible
i like the communities that i work in
and what we try to impress upon the
families that we serve other projects
is this thing called a growth mindset
which is to
enter out into the world
with this
keen understanding that everyone is
conspiring for your success
well that's not the way a lot of people
feel
well
i mean you know it is true that in a
certain type of community people are
just pulling for you all the time
well
yeah it's not the way that most people
operate but that has a lot to do with
our conditioning uh america has for so
long conditioned us to compete against
one another or to
you know look at one another or to other
or to create tribes and say that
they're this way so you know i can't
walk with them and support them and or
they're that way so i can't
you know follow their league but i think
we all have an opportunity and a choice
to i don't know where i'm going with
this this is what a hell of a leader
um
okay but
let's let's keep going let's keep going
yeah man don't worry we've got it um so
you have a lot of uh very direct
personal experience with poverty having
grown up in the projects at dc
now you're this award-winning social
entrepreneur how the heck did you get
through yeah you know i get it man i
also was once
like you
but
in the sense of you know i was a social
entrepreneur and like i got an award or
two and then sometimes people would hype
it up and then if you're in your shoes
you're like oh you know it's like it's
just
um just trying to do some work uh but
how did you go from the projects to
co-founding and being the ceo of this
thriving social enterprise well i think
one thing and so often
when people tell my story you know it
starts in the projects but i was blessed
that i had a single mother that worked
really hard um to make sure that we
always had a roof over our head outside
of public housing and i'm never going to
take that away from her and all the work
that she did
we definitely went without for days but
that woman would move hell in high water
to make sure that her boys were in a
position where they could be successful
my story started in a place that is not
unique
be honest um
single mom growing up in 90s dc in the
midst of a
crack uh epic a cracker that
ravaged
the black community like so many
communities not just in d.c but around
the country
yet
you know for me it was always being
involved in different programs and
uh definitely sports as a main driver
for my success keeping me focused and
giving me the discipline that i needed
uh you were a competitive football
player from early on right i was i still
feel the pain now man
how how early did they start you or did
you start yourself started definitely
installed myself started flagging four
and then uh contact football got started
at six
wow six
uh and what position did you start out
in
uh i was the if you believe this andrew
i was the center when i was a little kid
i was a star i was a stud center man i
was a stud center
well uh people who are just listening to
this jerry's a big guy but he's not that
big
nah i didn't play that i could i didn't
play cena all the way through it i
definitely started on the kids started
catching up to me with size
so you went from center to what position
uh i went to college as a wide receiver
so wow so if you got a d1 scholarship
you must have been a very high level
athlete throughout your high school
years is that right i was a hard worker
always a hard worker um for me nothing
ever came easy
uh sport
it made me what i am today in a lot of
aspects everything that i got whether it
was a scholarship whether it was getting
time on the field whether it was gaining
muscles i was a skinny kid you know i
really had to work related to that too
man
you hit the gym a little bit
uh so i i'd skipped a grade um it seems
like you were young when you graduated
from high school two was that right oh
yeah i was i was a 17 when i graduated
dude i have no idea how you'd be uh an
uh exceptional athlete and also be a
year younger than people because a lot
of the time you're a year older i was a
year younger and was small and scrawny
and always felt like i was
the asian runt uh and so i had this
massive chip on my shoulder about trying
to prove myself as a boy or a man which
in that case led me to get a lot of
fights that i generally lost
like i i ended up hitting the gym when i
was in my late teens but before that i
wrestled for a year and was terrible i
went out for the basketball team and got
cut
i did make the tennis team and
development some grit along the way i
hope so that there i guess i mean you
know
sticking to my nose and i mean we were
joking when when we walked in you were
like hey did you
have any political ties before you ran
for presidents and i was like no so
maybe you started going out for things
that i have no business going out for
man we're going to change it hopefully
we're going to end that trend to losing
though we'll end that trend you got some
wins in store oh well thank you for
saying so man i mean i certainly took an
l this past week and we were joking
about that with me
where you know i i uh uh made
a comment that i was wrong and uh pissed
a lot of people off and i've just been
uh saying yeah i get it i get it all
week yeah that's my grandmother told me
man don't stick your nose into something
you ain't trying to smell
you took on black twitter that was a bad
decision my friend
that was a bad decision
don't stick your nose in there
yeah so hopefully there could be peace
uh in the twitter verse uh because you
know i i certainly understand the
uh wrong headedness of my comment i hope
people know where my heart is well it's
like
i think it's less about your comments
you use the most basic
one everybody knows to stay away from he
has a black friend everybody knows that
andrew what's going on we gotta get some
more black people on your team you
talking about joe rogan come on man
somebody should have told you that oh
you know that they they were definitely
telling me all about it uh you know like
immediately thereafter and i had a bunch
of
uh conversations that were really
emotionally charged yeah uh with some
people i think you and i have in common
even like some of the people that i was
talking to and
it was a learning experience that's for
sure
um but i i certainly appreciate the
understanding that some people have
extended to me no 100 percent man and
i think even the the conversation that
we've been able to have i understand how
genuine you are and i think that's
important
we all make mistakes we all make
mistakes and i think the time that we
live in now
it becomes so easy to point the finger
at somebody and say oh look what they
did wrong
as if we all don't wake up every single
day and do things even not intentionally
but do things that offend people and
hurt people
no one of the stories that particularly
in this moment in time that i think we
all have
really should take some time to learn
from it's the story of the prodigal son
you know in the bible tells the story
about a gentleman that you know makes
this decision that they want to take
their birthright and head out into the
wilderness and be a man you know and
we've all had praise in our lives when
we head out there and what the gentleman
finds out very quickly is the world is a
very dark place
it ends up you know at the bottom of the
bottom eating out of
the same food as pigs
when this gentleman finds his way back
to his father's house
you know his father welcomes him with
open arms and
kills the fattest calf and gives him the
the robe off his back and puts his ring
on his finger
and
a lot of times when that story is told
people focus so much on that gentleman
that went out into the wilderness and
found his way back
what they ignore in that story is the
gentleman's brother who's also at the
house who goes to the father after he
returns and says you know how dare you
accept this guy back into our household
he spent half your bread like you know
like he stink he was with the pigs and
you're gonna
kill the fattest calf and throw a party
for this man
and the father talks about you know for
any of my flock you know when i welcome
back i'll do the same too many of us
like in this day and time are that
brother you know when people make
mistakes
we're so ready to throw them back out
into the world
but at least as a christian man
understanding that everybody doesn't
operate from the same ideology that's
their choice
but from the value system that i operate
from
you know we all have the responsibility
to choose love first
even when people make mistakes you made
a mistake
you know as long as you learn from it
and continue to move forward
you know you always got a friend in me
well thank you darris it means a lot to
me and certainly
uh i would love to see
a sense of humanity and forgiveness and
grace and tolerance when people screw up
because right now i think a lot of
people
screw up and then you know bad things
happen sometimes it's deserved sometimes
it's not
but i i do think that there's a very
very widespread fear of screwing up
that is out there in the world
um and
i have to say it doesn't feel good like
i've let people down a number of times
uh in public life
uh it's never been
a positive experience
um and
each time i'm like okay like you know
hopefully that's the last time but then
on some level you kind of know that
there
is never going to be a last time
unless you stop unless you stop
uh being a human being in some ways or
you stop doing things you know in the
political universe i think a lot of
times you get surrounded by a team and
folks and people that uh eliminate the
uh possibility of certain kinds of
mistakes but you also lose something
else too you know you lose like a degree
of
yourself yeah you know you become
less of a
person and more of like an institution
or an automaton i i agree with you man i
think
at the end of the day
to
to make mistakes is to be human
and
very sad is the day that we create a
world where people feel like they can't
make mistakes
um yesterday is a perfect example you
know i over booked myself the next thing
i know i'm missing meetings
and it was this period in the middle of
the day where i was like
feeling really bad and really down and i
got on my knees and i prayed and i was
just like god like
remove this from my spirit
like not because i didn't care
that i didn't miss the meeting you know
we'll reschedule and move forward
but because i know that i operate with
positive intent in everything that i do
and i think for a lot of people at the
end of the day they can't look
themselves in the mirror and say that
firmly that they're operating in a world
positive so it makes it very difficult
makes it much easier to point the
fingers when somebody else makes a
mistake that's the end of the day that's
the only thing that matters is what is
your uh intent behind the actions that
you make
i've been an entrepreneur for a long
time and you know the worst feeling in
the world
waiting in line at the post office time
is money and you cannot waste your time
doing something that you can do from the
comfort of your own home with stamps.com
you can print official postage right
from your computer save time money give
you better records and make your
customers happy
for more than 20 years stamps.com has
been enabling small businesses and
individual consumers like you
to power the post office right at home
stop overpaying for shipping get things
done better faster cheaper at stamps.com
sign up with promo code yang for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
necessary just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code yang you'll be glad you
did
[Music]
when you say this darius it reminds me
of my younger self and i'm a bit older
than you i've got some ears on you but
i used to be so hard on myself
when i messed up uh you should apologize
to your younger self though or just like
almost cripplingly angry at myself
uh and i think that there was like a
real
[Music]
lack of confidence that uh i had when i
was young and the skinny uh asian kid
who got called uh you know [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and all sorts of other things in
my town which was put out on the
italian-american
and
so
i had
something that i was supposed to be good
at which was school
but being good at school doesn't make
you feel particularly good about
yourself when you're you know like the
uh the runty asian kid that's like oh
well you know my grades are good
especially in
the area i grew up in and so
there was like this real desire to prove
myself uh as a man boy and then man
that just
spurred me forward throughout my
adolescence and my 20s and then when i
would mess up
like i i would
just be so like i remember screaming at
myself in private i hope i wasn't doing
it in front of people but
i was like
just and
as i got older it was like the single
biggest thing i needed to
learn in order to
um one be able to operate successfully
but two
uh to be able to have like a decent
positive healthy relationship um was to
kind of let some of that
uh
that
anger at myself go yeah
like some kind of self-forgiveness
and i think part of it is that i didn't
have uh the
sense of faith to fall back on it it
seems like you were brought up in yeah
i can resonate with that so much andrew
to be honest like
wow i can resonate with that so much
i think we all hit those points right
where it's like
are you going to hold on to the baggage
and the trauma you're going to forgive
yourself
and then being able to forgive yourself
ultimately forgive those around you
and i went through a similar
time in my life
where i was learning to forgive myself
it was right around 2019
roughly a year or two before the
pandemic
and
i found myself at this period where i
was on planes every single day
um the organization was growing and tell
people about your organization for a sec
too
and so good projects is a
is an amazing collective of passionate
individuals in washington dc
uh that are focused on eradicating
poverty and the largest density of
public housing in washington dc
incredible yeah
our goal is to support 500 families on
that pathway to achieving their version
of the american dream by 2030
and we're well on our way to that goal
with our first 45 families having
enrolled in the program in the last year
wow
so 2019 you're on planes all the time
fundraising for this org uh yeah man
yeah man by the grace of god it's not
very often especially in the nonprofit
space that you have this idea
and within your first two years you're
able to take you know an idea on a white
board in your college dorm room to an
organization that was sustaining a
revenue above two million dollars a year
wow
that is incredible
by the grace of god by the grace of god
but
you know to
the point that
you made
it's too often that you know god
provides favor on somebody's life and
then
you know we use that for things that
don't necessarily fill our cups
and for me that was you know you get all
of this press coming in all this
notoriety both for the impact and then
the ability to scale an organization so
what inevitably happens for any founder
of an organization whether for-profit or
non-profit speaking invites i'm guessing
speaking advice man people want to talk
to you um people want to fund your work
and every single day i found myself at
one conference or the next conference at
dinners
um
experience in this world that as a young
black man coming out of washington dc i
didn't even know existed um so tell me
about the weirdest [ __ ] that they had
you at
you don't have to you know i'll throw
that out i was once on a sailboat in
fiji like wow yeah i never seen a yacht
that big in my life
that's nuts yeah oh my gosh private
planes the world of philanthropy is is
it's not it's changed a lot it's changed
a lot
it's changed a lot so you were on these
planes and then so i'll i'll
relate my version of that which is not
quite as dramatic as yours on either
side
but i started a non-profit in 2011
and
while i was fundraising i found myself
going a lot of conferences
and making the case trying to get people
to get excited about venture for america
yeah uh and the more i did of it uh the
further away from the work i felt
because 100 they're like the young
entrepreneurs you're trying to help or
the startups uh you're trying to foster
and then there are the conferences and
the rich people in the corporations you
got to do the fundraising that's the
role of any executive director if you're
not the expectation if you're not doing
those things you're not doing your job
effectively you know
you know it sounds like you fell into
that trap and i did it too
and
you find yourself just moving moving
moving moving movement and you look up
and weeks have gone by and you haven't
touched the work that you work so hard
yeah that could sneak up on you really
good you know and for me i didn't
realize at the time it's easy for me to
talk about it in hindsight i can
directly point into that thing but at
the time there was this inadequacy and
depression and anxiety that i was always
feeling every single day despite the
fact that i'm looking around there's
something
punishing
about being like this ambassador for
your idea or project and even though it
is you and you love this idea and a
project
um but you you feel a little bit like
a performer
uh and if you do it for a while it can
really grind your spirit
certainly and take away from the
ambition and the passion that you had
when you got started yes
because you didn't start it
was pitching people some people did
don't let me get wrong some people do
some people do do that uh
i think that's what joins you and i
together is that we didn't do it for
that you know it's a blessing to be able
to be in the studio and have these level
of conversations but
i think we're both at points in our
careers where
this is
this is not how i want to be spending my
time you know
it's the winter it's a little bit gray
and yucky and so sometimes it's hard to
be upbeat sometimes it's hard to be
positive and when you do feel yourself
dragging sometimes you just say hey i'll
trudge through this but a lot of the
time you actually need some help and i
don't mean that friend who kind of
half-heartedly listens to you
and doesn't really give you true
guidance because that's honestly not
what friends are for i mean a
professional therapist and mental health
resource i'm so proud to be sponsored by
betterhelp.com which is helping over a
million people take charge of your
mental health it's like uber for
therapists the person's on call for you
all of the time
i want you to start living a happier
life today
and as a listener you'll get 10 percent
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang
join the hundreds of thousands of people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelphelp.com
[Music]
well for me
i wound up running for president because
i felt like
my
vision for improving people's lives
wasn't going to be achieved through the
nonprofit i was working at certainly
and
the presidential campaign did
help bring the
concept of and everyone knows is not my
idea universal basic income to a a
broader group
and that was what i was after
and it it did make me feel better um
what was funny there is that the
presidential campaign was highly
unlikely uh when i started it but i
never felt better okay i was sitting in
my mom's apartment here
in manhattan not that far from where
we're sitting
and
planning my presidential campaign that
made really no sense on the face of it
um with a few young scrappy idealistic
people who believed in me and we were
just there we were eating chinese food
or indian food on the regular and you
know talking about things to go on the
website and whatnot um and in many ways
that was the high point of the campaign
[Laughter]
those early days i mean there were other
high points too and like you know
there's a lot of joy and love and um i
will confess to you and people might
sense this about me anyway like i really
miss the purity
and joy of the presidential campaign um
because there there was like uh
just like a very clear intent and
motivation
most people instinctively recognize that
it was just a person because no one
would send
the
asian guy no one has ever heard of to go
do something so there was no there was
no like
you know strange
uh agenda it was just a guy being like
hey we should start giving everyone
money and
um
that purity certainly
is a very different place than i am now
even though i still have the same vision
and the same
goals and the same agenda
but it doesn't feel the same in large
part because now
i'm a thing
in the way i was not then and then i was
just a man wandering iowan new hampshire
uh and people
you know decided to get behind me
and i try to
stay
like stay human stay just like the same
guy
but they're they're all of these things
around me
and and uh it's been
yeah it's been
a process for me too honestly
i think the biggest thing to just
continue to focus on is integrity and
not to take yourself too seriously
and i think you do a good job of that oh
thanks man you know like it's been
really fun hanging out with you the last
day
um
but
at the end of the day it's kind of ties
back to i think a lot of the issues that
we're seeing in this country
like inevitably that we're all taking
ourselves too seriously the pandemic
taught us any things you can take a work
meeting in your underwear
i guess that's one lesson i will say so
you and i had lunch earlier today uh and
there was a mother dancing with her baby
and they just got up and started dancing
with her never miss a good dance break
and she was very happy to have a dance
partner and it was a bit of joy a bit of
levity never never never miss a good
dance break man like
life is short like at the end of the day
you can walk around this goes back to
the growth mindset versus deficit
mindset
like that is a perfect example you're
sitting in a
food cafeteria in the middle of new york
and you see a mother that
for whatever reason the song has caught
uh her hips and she's just dancing with
her little one-year-old baby by herself
just having the time in your life
and
for most of us when we in those moments
were dancing by ourselves
so that was an opportunity that i saw
you know it was a pretty cool song like
freak like
how can i make her feel just a little
less alone in this moment and there we
were you know dancing like how do you
take a metaphor like that and apply it
to life
like there's only two types of people in
this world at the end of the day you
have energy takers and energy givers
like those of us that are truly going
out here trying to change the world and
make it something special and better for
those that come after us are energy
givers the people that get up you know
make that woman feel a little less alone
dancing in the middle of the cafeteria
as opposed to somebody that looks at her
and says oh is she crazy because she
dancing as opposed to nah she enjoying
life energy giver i love that yeah yeah
uh
one of the
people that's helped
your
career along early on are good projects
uh was a guy named frank luntz yeah
great dude uh i know frank
um
i like prank too
um
and one of the things you and i bonded
over was the the sense that we need a
different approach
uh beyond tribalism when it comes to
politics that this two warring factions
thing is not
a winning situation it's not it's not
it's not a winning situation just like
the football team in washington isn't
like you know we got a job that's a
rough day i mean you know better i do we
got to jump ship and jump ship now like
oh the athlete that may understand sort
of what we've created in the political
system is two teams competing against
each other wow um and what we've seen
not just at congress but it's sort of
every level of government is that when
you have two teams competing with each
other at the end of the day nothing is
going to get done at least nothing that
genuinely supports the people that put
those people in positions to serve
like this is not an effective system
which is one of the reasons why i'm so
supportive of you know what you're doing
with the forward party
i think we have a huge opportunity even
in this cycle in 2022 to really start to
introduce what it looks like to have
difference in the political system i
love it
let's
share this work and share this vision
with a ton more
people in the next number of months man
makes plans and god laughs inshallah
we'll see what happens man yeah we'll
see what happens um so when i met frank
i had read some stuff about him and
heard of him as this
uh dark republican pollster type no and
then i sit down with them and i think
wow this guy's
very
well intended data-driven reasonable
shared a lot of the same goals and i
will confess to you darius i've had that
experience
now a number of times with people where
going in i was like oh like this
person's uh you know like a certain type
um
bad intentions
evil conservative quite often wow you
would think it was almost like somebody
wanted you to think that right and then
i talked to them and i'm like i really
like this person this person's fairly
positive and
wants good things to happen for a lot of
people maybe sometimes we disagree on on
some aspect
um but
nothing like whatever the heck they're
portrayed like on television yes and now
that this has happened to me
over and over again now i try to take
everything with a grain of salt where if
i meet someone i'm trying to come fresh
certainly i would say political pundits
are like pro wrestlers
like dude
i was an enormous wrestling fan growing
up it was one of like the ways that
i you know matured honestly so i'm older
than you by you know 20 years so my
entire wrestling frame of reference is
at least a generation earlier but i kept
up with it through
the entire
rock stone cold cena
like that entire right mysterio yeah ray
mysterio still freaking at it um and i
became friends with a bunch of wrestlers
over the last number of years really
yeah fun facts
totally
great guys mick foley incredible person
diamond dallas paige legitimately one of
the most positive people you will ever
meet
so anyway just letting you know that um
when i was running for president
half the time i was channeling
professional wrestling promos what was
your alter ego's name during the
campaign was andrew yang i would just
show up my entrance music was returning
it wasn't just andrew yang on the
campaign
it was there was one particular time
it was in south carolina uh it was the
clyburn
uh fish fry
and
they set up such a high bar for the
candidates and so you can look this up
online
where all of us were wearing these
ridiculous
um
you know
like it was either blue or purple
t-shirts so like it's me joe biden
elizabeth warren
uh better like all of us just started
standing in this bullpen and you're told
to go out to a group of south
carolinians and just
talk to them for 60 seconds and then get
off
so think about that task
so people would go out and they would
say these things i just channeled uh the
rock really you know
i like what it went out there and thank
goodness and the people of south
carolina who hear this who were there
like who were there like thank goodness
i had some supporters in the crowd
because i walked out and just sort of
like did like a kind of randy orton-ish
like i'm here sort of wrestling and then
some people were like yeah where can we
find this video is that on youtube that
this is somewhere on youtube you can
look up jim clyburn
fish fry and then you know
like if i had not been a pro wrestling
fan
um my campaign would have been entirely
different and uh probably been a dud
yeah i understand so you get the analogy
then it's like these political pundits
they're they're going on tv as
characters yeah completely and this is
one of the things that you know
why frank and i have clashed over the
years him is representative of an entire
faction of media pundits that you know
get paid to go out
and play these characters that sell
division and that's not uh jab at frank
or
any of the other guys
it's the business it's the business you
know i've been there and that exists on
both sides of the aisle we have an
opportunity again in this generation to
show that
not first create something different but
to show there's an appetite for
something different it's my podcast like
this is so important on the podcast we
have an opportunity to roll out with
the right to shower is so important is
why the work
good projects does is so important
you know at the end of the day like
and you'll know the stats better than me
you wrote an amazing op-ed in washington
post today
i think that you have a generation of
young people that are coming up now that
want something different
they want something different in
television they want something different
politically
they want different clothes
you know but well let's give them
something different man you would know a
hundred times better than i would i'd do
what the young people want
uh but let's give it to them whatever
they want let's give it to them
you're a cool guy
oh thank you for saying so man
[Music]
so you and i want to fight poverty and
one of the things that we've clicked on
is that
web3 technologies have the potential to
be one of the most profound
opportunities
to combat poverty that maybe we have
ever seen certainly 100
100
100 percent at the end of the day we can
sit here and celebrate
covers of magazines or write tons of
articles about the next
crypto billionaire and celebrate that
person like it's the greatest thing
since
you know jesus christ but at the end of
the day
like we should be ashamed of ourselves
like we're creating wealth
in
the most expansive time in history for
people that more often than not not to
say this is the case all the time but
that more often than not we're already
good
while we sit here and there's
populations like the good zone in dc in
southwest washington dc
where the average income is 14 000 a
year wow and we think that that's
perfectly acceptable
like you and i also agree on the point
that poverty is a social construct that
doesn't need to exist totally
unnecessary you know financial
technologies that have been created
recently like cryptocurrencies
um and the utilization of web 3 is the
latest sort of iteration of how we can
do it it obviously allows us to do it at
a much quicker and more efficient pace
or we could have eradicated poverty a
long time ago and this has been a
relatively recent shift though we've
been we've been able to do it for years
but there was a period when there was
genuine scarcity and not enough to go
around but we passed that point we don't
live in that time now we don't live in
that time now the second that they
started building them rockets
that looked like dildos and shooting
them up to the moon
the time had come and gone where you
could tell me that people need to be
living on the street i agree it's
completely unacceptable like completely
it was actually pre spaceship even like
we could have done this stuff the thing
that really lit a fire under me in my
brain
was during the financial crisis 2008
2009 markets crashing et cetera et
cetera they print four trillion dollars
to shore up wall street more or less
and i don't remember voting for it no
one remembers voting for it i don't
remember anyone being like where are we
gonna get the money et cetera et cetera
but i gotta tell you darius i i saw that
[ __ ] and was like we just did what we
just printed four trillion dollars to
essentially
make the banks whole
uh and i took from that
this incredible
revelation
that if we wanted to we could have
produced four trillion dollars worth of
wealth good services for the american
people
at any point up to then you know
push came to shove
and i genuinely think
that we are still dealing with the
anger and the aftermath of that
financial crash
um because that financial crash and now
it seems like ancient history because
it's you know
uh
13 14 years ago now
uh but it gave rise to the tea party
uh it gave rise to just a lot of
populist anger where up up until then it
was not clear
to me even
uh it was not clear to me how rigged and
jacked up the game was until they
pulled that
printer lever for the 4 trillion
uh in
08.
after that i was like we can do anything
and here we are i mean when i was
running for president on this stuff
people were always like oh where you
gonna get the money where you get the
money and then we just did it again for
uh coveted relief which by the way i was
you know all for some version of it the
problem was that so little of that went
to the people in the good zone or people
around the country
i did the math is like 17 of it went to
people and families 83 of it went to
banks airlines
giant firms and now they're finding out
that a lot of the money that got plowed
to these companies didn't go to payroll
preservation or whatever the heck it you
know like so which was by the way
entirely predictable like if you'd
wanted to you could reverse that and
been like hey guess what we're gonna
send the money straight to the employees
send the money straight to the people
and then you can figure out like the
you know the corporate balance sheet
yourselves i mean that would have been a
very dramatic way to do it but i would
have been for it i think if you'd asked
any american hey
we're going to print 2 trillion dollars
do you want 83 of it to go to the
corporates or 83 of it to go to
you know to you and your neighbors um so
i've been after this more or less since
uh 08
that we have entered an era of
abundance if we want that for our people
but it turns out that our government
doesn't really respond to
the people
uh and
man you better start and that that's
what we need to change but you and i are
going to work on activating
uh the
value creation of web3 technologies to
help the people that you're serving
uh in the good zone
and other people around the country as
quickly as possible because you're right
that right now
it's not addressing
the
imbalances and ills the way that it
could and it's going to be good for
everyone if we can
uh bring the opportunity to the need
100
if you think about just the foundation
of cryptocurrencies the foundation this
is pre-sub road days got a bad rep
during that time you know
cryptocurrencies were created
as a financial vehicle to provide access
to capital to communities that otherwise
wouldn't
most often than not communities that
would didn't have the outsider system
yeah
and
somewhere along the line
we let greed creep in the same way that
we do again so many other things with
this deficit mindset
where
when we step out here and we make these
bold claims that okay we're going to
utilize the blockchain or web3
technologies to be able to provide more
access to capital to communities people
will look at us like oh my god that's so
crazy to think about it's like no this
is what it was made for in the first
place we just put it on cash app and
then it became a thing where we're like
oh it's a commodity now because there's
a dollar value associated with it
right but again back to my earlier point
as we sit here and celebrate how much
wealth is being created in this moment
we should sit here and be ashamed of
ourselves how that's not helping people
as much as it could or should yeah more
often that wealth is not touching those
that truly need it yeah it's true
[Music]
uh i was talking to bishop td jakes uh
the other day and and
he
was deeply concerned about the future of
uh black wealth and income yeah um
because he said look what wealth and
income yeah i mean you're starting from
you know a much lower
place and uh base than you should the
average net worth of an african american
in this country it's like zero dollars
that's crazy
what like that's crazy andrew like what
are we doing what are we doing
uh and so bishop jakes asked me to
project out whether that is going to get
better or worse given gci and the rest
of it and i actually saw the study that
was released a couple of years ago and
it said it's
going to go down not up
and the metaphor i used with bishop
jakes was that ai and
advancing technologies are like an
economic
hurricane
and in a storm who gets hurt the most
the people in the lowest lying areas
have the least ability to get to higher
ground and seek shelter in the rest of
it and so who is that in terms of the
economy it's people of color who have
lower levels of
access and resources and opportunity to
begin with and so then if you send ai
through that
you know it's going to get worse not
better and i will say that bishop jake
seemed completely unsurprised by
anything i was saying he's a very savvy
guy so he kind of wanted me to say it
but he knew it yeah no it's true
but knowing it
again and not doing something about it
we got to do something about it makes us
just as bad as the people that are
conspiring for that to happen in the
first place and that's one of the things
that unifies you and i like to think
uh is that we want all these good things
to happen
but we don't want to wait
so we're just going to do them ourselves
to the extent you know that there's like
i i
you know obviously try to get a hold of
the government because i think there are
certain things we need the government
for but we also just need to make as
many
good things happen as possible in the
here and now and not necessarily wait
certainly and i think what you and i
both have also proven to the market
you know anywhere is that you can do
good for yourself and doing good for
others
you know i'm blessed to have been able
to scale an amazing organization and
good projects and even now as we venture
into more for-profit things
uh but i've been able to create a
wonderful life for myself and my family
doing that
you know will i be the next tech
billionaire you know only lord knows but
i do know along the way that we're going
to create a lot of wealth for people
that otherwise wouldn't have had access
to the opportunity to do it
but not enough of us are operating
through the world so with that mindset
at the end of the day we all rise
together
people don't want to think that way i
think it's a zero-sum game and it's
truly not
in the worst case scenario is that you
know at the end of the day if we keep
going at this rate that we are now we
create
poorer and poorer and poorer and poorer
and more desperate people
you know history does truly repeat
itself andrew and that's not me being a
pessimist at all
you know the foundation of the work that
i do is following the successes of the
past the past and trying to create those
in a way that benefits the families that
i serve
but if you look at history it shows that
if you create a poor enough class
you know people won't just fall out of
the political system they'll turn
against you
you know we don't want that to be the
case here in this country yeah i'm
greatly concerned about what's coming
when you talk about
this zero-sum game mentality
i came to politics as someone who'd
been in startups and so you're always
looking for the value creation the
win-win-win uh and the rest of it and
then you get into politics and people
want it to become zero-sum i win you
lose there's no growth you are such an
uplifting and inspiring figure darius
how can people help you
man i wouldn't be doing my job as an
executive director if i didn't say they
could donate and support the project
that we're working on and that's
goodprojects.org yeah yeah then go to
goodprojects.org
yeah or darius baxter personally i know
everyone watching and listening to this
is going to want to lend a hand you're
changing lives uh in
a community that you know intimately and
that needs it and we're going to do some
great work together you and i we're
going to take
the
potential of web 3 technologies and
actually improve people's lives on the
ground and i hope that happens right in
the good zone yeah we're not hoping you
and i aren't really hopers we're more
doers we're more doers like and it's
it's operating with this belief why
would the vision be placed in our heart
if it wasn't already ours
like
we were it's not serendipitous that we
found ourselves together it's not
standing up just we found ourselves
together in this moment it's not you
know by chance we found ourselves
together in this moment thinking about
the same grand vision for communities
you know going back to some of the
earliest points that we made when you
operate from a place of integrity and
love and you're doing things to try to
help others
more often than not you're going to meet
other people to help you work towards
that goal
more often than not you're going to find
yourself with an over abundance of
resources to be able to complete what
you need
you know all that oh that that's
uh that's the dream
for sure but it has happened to me
several times in in my life i wonder why
and
you could not even for a moment think
that it was just you like there's
absolutely no way to feel that having
seen what i've seen and done what i've
done
where you you set out and let's say you
start an organization and in some ways
you have no business starting that
organization
and then
people
reach out a hand and help you in ways
that you never would have expected or
imagined and then it happens again and
then people come work with you
and that the best feeling of all and i
know you can relate to this is when you
can bring someone into an environment
where they get a better opportunity
because that's so much what people want
for themselves and it makes them
stronger more confident more optimistic
that that's what i love to do more than
anything else in the world
and that's what we have to do for as
many people as possible
certainly
i think both of us would also take it a
step further and say people still have
to be able to take that first step yeah
you know the thing that joins us and you
joke about it but you're very serious so
we're doers
like before we had resources before we
had platforms um to talk about the work
that we
have the blessings to serve and do now
we were out there in the world creating
a pathway for ourself like you talk
about your journey to becoming president
you know you just said okay i'm going to
do this and you develop the strategy and
you're in my journey running for
president i think you said becoming
president that would have been different
[Laughter]
you know and shalom that's what you want
and i claim that for you know who am i
to tell you otherwise
thank you for saying that darius i you
know i i will say i don't
um
i ran for president not because i had
some deep-seated desire to be president
i just wanted good things to happen
and i'm still at the same place you know
like if if i die
uh and i've never been president united
states i'd be a okay with that like if i
die and i didn't do my utmost to help as
many people as i could then like that
that wouldn't be the example i want to
set for
you know my boys myself um
so you know i'm not driven by that
particular
uh specific
ambition yeah um i i will say that
this country and you you it's you're a
combination of the same things i think
that i am where you see how dark the
future
uh can be
and you see that there are a lot of
things that we can do that could improve
on it so you feel like that this urgency
um so i'm gonna do as much as possible i
don't know what that role looks like but
uh thank you for saying what you said
yeah end of the day all we have a
responsibility to do is to show up and
to be vessels
both of us
i take i relieve all pressure from you
and i hope that the listeners can learn
something from this in this moment too i
relieve all pressure from you
to wake up every day feeling like that
much weight is on your shoulders we'll
first give you a hunch but then a second
like it's just too much to carry
you know at the end of the day
you've been blessed with a vision and
i'll say this to you andrew but i speak
it to all of our listeners like you've
been blessed with a vision a divine one
at that to go out there and to help
people and to support people and to
change their lives and provide a better
future one that you probably can't even
imagine at this point because it's so
big
like you don't have to worry you don't
have to stress
all you need to do is wake up every day
put them tennis shoes on make sure you
put them on the right feet time up
tights of your own trip and just keep
moving forward and moving forward with
love and integrity and compassion and
everything will work itself out i
promise you you ain't never have to
worry about a bill being paid you don't
have to worry about your health your
sanity everything will be taken care of
that is excellent almost divine advice
my friend and i will do my best to take
it darius baxter goodprojects.org let's
do some good together my friend so we're
going to do some good together yes we
are
[Music]
you